[Music]
now whatever your views are on donald
trump there's no denying that the
unprecedented raid on his palm beach
home earlier this week has set our
country on a dangerous new course and
there's no turning back the fbi's right
on
changed the country that we grew up and
we grew up believing that hey our
government will apply the law equally to
all americans whether you're a
republican or a democrat we're seeing
more and more that that country no
longer exists
law enforcement at the highest levels of
government whether it's the doj the
department of homeland security the fbi
and now even the irs have been
weaponized to target the political
opponents of the uniparty the permanent
washington and the biden regime
attorney general merrick garland has
already issued a stark warning to anyone
who dares to disagree with these tactics
that are all hallmarks of a dictatorship
let me address recent unfounded attacks
on the professionalism of the fbi and
justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
so you are not allowed to disagree with
the fbi that is the new message the
security state will label you an
extremist for daring to challenge or
disagree with the regime's weaponization
of law enforcement
they talk about defending the blue they
talk about defending law enforcement
officers
they fly the flags put on the bumper
stickers
and yet
if it doesn't suit their political
purposes then they remain silent or even
attack law enforcement officers the
senator talked about the fbi's attack on
our constitutional republic
another
republican senator
accused them of of of being a third
world marxist
dictators and yet
the silence is deafening these guys
aren't republicans joe these guys are
extremists
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight